as the smoke settles from the brawl
between the x-men and that big weird
blue guy it's time to look at some of
the acts scenes from x-men apocalypse
while not all of these scenes would have
changed the course of the film we're
still crossing our claws that these
scratch scenes make it onto the home
versions of the movie hope you brought
your ruby court sunglasses there are
some potentially dangerous spoilers
ahead cancelling Jubilees fireworks
there was ever a chance for Jubilee to
shine x-men apocalypse was it a fan
favorite from the comics and cartoon for
years we wanted Jubilee to have her
big-screen moment instead she played the
same role she did in the previous films
just another background student who
doesn't do anything
Fandango reveals that director Bryan
Singer wanted her to shine and filmed a
scene showcasing her fireworks
likability he said quote we do have a
moment where Jubilee uses her powers and
you'll see that on the DVD we wanted
more Jubilee
it's okay Bryan we all did bedazzled
another heartbreaking character cut the
rumored Dazzler cameo the blonde popstar
mutant was supposedly going to show up
on an album cover the ex kids find in a
record store adding fuel to the fire
were rumors that real-life blonde pop
star Taylor Swift drop by the set of
apocalypse seemingly proven by producer
Simon Kinberg tweeted photo of himself
James McAvoy sophie Turner and the Swift
one herself
Kinberg later admitted that the photo
wasn't from the set but from backstage
at Swift's Montreal show and that she
wasn't going to dazzle audiences after
all still hopefully we'll get that
glimpse of the disco dancing mutants
album on the DVD release special
features brain freeze while we're on the
subject of the Eckstein's mall trip
there were more Nightcrawler scenes cut
from the film for starters the final cut
didn't include the TV spot showing Kurt
Wagner experiencing brain freeze from
some type of smoothie according to an
interview with Fandango Bryan Singer
acts to get another scene with
Nightcrawler quote they're moving
through the mall and they're all have
remarks about the other people that they
don't fear us and he thinks the mall is
this paradise Phoenix powered
first-person shooter this picture of
Jean Grey holding Scott Summers neck and
helping him aim his optic blast was used
in the promotional material for x-men
apocalypse but the scene never actually
happened in the film it's a shame the
film didn't include it because it shows
a degree of
between the two future lovebirds
especially since Cyclops was scared
almost ashamed of his powers throughout
the first half of the film hopefully
we'll see it in the special features
splitting the summer siblings when the
Xavier Institute explodes Alix summers
better known as havoc dies in the blast
his brother Cyclops doesn't get to say
goodbye as Stryker soldiers storm the
Xavier school ruins and started
abducting students just minutes after
the explosion Brian singer explained
that he removed a heartfelt farewell
scene between the two summers bros you
said it slowed things down just a bit
too much quote if you sat in a theater
and watched it with all the scenes back
in it may seem good but slow and I don't
want the audience to feel that it could
be worse at least it wasn't like Cyclops
is death in the Last Stand thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which scene you wish
they'd kept in the final cut